[موسيقى]
ملفات ساخنه وتحديات عده تواجه القمه
العربيه الثانيه 32 في مدينه جده التي
تاتي في ظل ظروف امنيه معقده تمر بها
المنطقه العربيه والعالميه على حد سواء ما
ابرز هذه الملفات ملف الازمه السودانيه من
ابرز الملفات المطروحه على طاوله القمه
العربيه وسط توقعات بتحرك عربي واسع
لانهاء حاله الاقتتال استكمالا للدوري
السعودي القائم حاليا عمليه السلام في
اليمن واتمامها ستكون من اولويات القمه
العربيه حيث من المتوقع ان يكون هناك دعم
عربي للتوافق اليمني المنبثقي من الاتفاق
السعودي اليمني لتحقيق الاستقرار الدائم
في البلاد ايضا من ابرز ملفات المطروحه في
قمه جده عوده سوريا الى الحضن العربي
وتعزيزه اعاده في المشهد العربي عبر اطلاق
مبادرات وتوصيات مرتقبه في بيان القمه
الختامي الامن الغذائي هو الاخر يعتبر من
الملفات المشتركه على اجنده القمه العربيه
ما يستدعي ضروره تحقيق السله الغذائيه
الواحده التي تحقق الاكتفاء الذاتي للعرب
بحسب الخبراء الامن المائي كذلك ياتي ضمن
ابرز ملفاته قمه جدا لا سيما في ظل
النزاعات الاقليميه الراهنه سواء مرتبطه
في السودان ومصر مع اثيوبيا او في سوريا
والعراق مع تركيا ملفات اخرى سيناقشها
الزعماء العرب في قمتهم 32 الاوضاع
السياسيه في ليبيا ودعم الجهود لتحديد
موعد للانتخابات بالاضافه الى النهوض
بالعمل العربي المشترك ووضع اليه الزاميه
لتطبيق ومتابعه مخرجات قرارات القمه
العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي من مدينه جده
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات